all right
[Music]
can I show you
at least at least on my phone I said I
just I just commented that you strangle
Carlos okay go ahead oh no oh God
when I keep scrolling past her on the I
can't
on the on the on the on my phone this is
the next guy that pops up
here I put it in the pressure
dude okay we could play the game with
him right JJ dude that looks like that
that tell me that doesn't look like uh
what's it called like you remember that
key and peel sketch where they're doing
all the different football players
lazarius Hutchinson okay don't say
anything it looks it looks like they got
Keenan and Kellen merger into one person
it looks like black diamond Townsend
so what do you he looks like a roster he
looks like a Rastafari in Frankenstein
let's just put a different big head on
there yeah it's actually not yeah go
ahead
um I'm gonna say
uh I'll guess after you
failure to appear selling drugs at a
Sublime with Rome concert okay
uh
uh I'm going to say drugs okay what do
we have what do we have so there was
four counts he got uh first was
possession of weed I win second was
carrying a pistol unlawfully uh third
was drugs again and fourth was failure
to appear
honestly I don't know honestly honestly
not as not as bad as I thought it was
gonna be right by the you know what
that's how he looks never judge a
Criminal by its cover I've learned that
today I was
honestly I mean let me tell you
something I don't judge every black man
with a new Jack I know I I know it's
funny but I mean I know you you though
you know
um you know didn't do and you try to
figure out what they did have you guys
ever done it with mugshotties because
that's my most favorite like I mean I'm
down okay so that's all right you know
what let's have some fun what do you say
you want to have fun no I got it nobody
else go I have the answers okay you are
guessing yeah Royce already has it up
yeah he's already got it he always has
mug shot he's up it's [ __ ] how do you
think I come so
here we go all right I will give I will
give no information no one look it up
nobody cheat it's not fun if you cheat
I'll give it I'm talking to chat I'm
sorry I'm talking to the chat too don't
cheat
this is fun for me because I never get
to play I did that's why I said I'll
hold I'm hosting now so let's go what do
we think what are we doing
go ahead pessie theft okay that's your
guess JJ what's up okay good guess uh
and uh Frozen I'm gonna say DUI
okay chat room the chat room have
anything to say that's true clear from
you online
um
well
for those guessing and those playing at
home operating a vehicle without a
license and speeding not that bad not
that bad okay you don't really not much
to fix there fellas thanks
yeah
I think that people are going to say
that's fixable but you know no that is
fixable that's easy that's nothing that
that's that that's that
any of us you know what I mean that's
not you know
so
uh let's go back to the thought is right
you ready
let's game now
ready
all right our next contestant in the
thought is right
[Music]
um let's uh pull this lady up
what do we think
locking it in drugs okay
I'm gonna say prostitution okay all
right I want to say disturb like
disturbing the peace okay like like she
was drunk in public or something I want
to say drugs plus a dollar I'm gonna do
the prices right I think no I also can
also give another thing uh breaking
Marsh's heart
the only information yeah the the only
information I have on this one is
arrested for out-of-county Warrant okay
we all were terrible on that one oh I
just saw the next contestant all right
all right all right all right all right
all right all right
all right
okay what do we got on this one ready
all right what are we guessing what do
we guess oh boy oh
I'm gonna say assault for sure domestic
yeah domestic violence with
strangulation
all right all right all right all right
all right
shoplifting
sure all right well I guess if I had to
give it a one it would be Pepsi because
it was theft less than twenty five
hundred dollars so that would go
damn it but that's the area but by the
way we do Whose Line is in anywhere
rules here so pessy a thousand points
you know she stole my heart
but by the way keep keep that energy
when we have through the hoedown at the
end
um
okay slow down yeah exactly the okay
shout out so you spin the wheel but it's
just tits oh but here you go again
all right what do we have here
that's prostitution right there all
right I'm gonna have to go with JJ on
this one all right Final Answer assault
oh also again breaking Rush is hard all
right breaking my heart she is point uh
no prostitution right we have simple
battery
that was close that Pepsi was a bit
pessy out of everyone was definitely the
closest okay so let's see who's I
watched a lot of din do let's see who's
next let's see who's this is doing what
he's doing where I'm trying someone else
ah JJ the master has become the student
all right
you're breaking my heart
I'm gonna say I'm porn between DUI and
drugs so I'll just go drugs
everyone locked in yeah okay let's see
what do you got
my darling no we get that you want to
give her your penis what's your guess
what's her crime I'm not yeah what's her
crime uh DUI all right well guess what
fellas unfortunately
um if you want to hook up with her you
better make sure you know how to block
because she is domestic violence oh
I don't care I don't care but first off
who's this who's the [ __ ] that had the
call-in domestic violence on this 100
pound girl right
all right now in the next one again this
one may oh God this one's gonna be too
easy I already know this is gonna be too
easy but even still I'm going to show it
to you fellas what did she do drugs
okay impersonating Sasha Banks I was
gonna say the same thing JJ but uh drugs
and again breaking Marsh's heart okay
he's showing the smell of her own fart
too much
now when I say this You're gonna laugh
possession of marijuana
yeah
no [ __ ]
all right folks this is very seriously
uh we've taken these very serious here I
was not keeping score all right I got
one for you this is the final ball no no
no I'm doing this
you could do whatever you want I'm the
host
um
next I want I prefer JJ guessing
um more fun okay who's this
oh [ __ ] what do we got
uh having a shitty late night talk show
that's not merch
oh wow
[Music]
um possession no
that doesn't look like this making
Merkel if she if she never married into
royalty
she's got a smirk on her face so it
almost makes me want to go to UI okay
that okay Glock are you locking it in
I'm walking back okay locking it in
Frozen
uh I am going to go with
either assault or domestic
okay Pepsi I wanted to say I'm going to
say assaulted
sorry also again uh breaking Marsha's
heart hello
third degree assault I only have Frozen
we got it all right good job so far
um is it bad that I'm making a lot of my
guesses based on ethnicity well you're
right I've been nailing them oh I have
all right guys you know what that means
we've made it to the final round and of
course the final round is the
um
multi mug shoddy challenge
foreign
they were all arrested all of them were
arrested together what did they do
trespassing
[Music]
theft
yeah shoplifting
this seems organized this is some
[ __ ] uh
well guys I'll have you know it was
organized this is mug shot is a
throwback from 2009 the cast of Vampire
Diaries they were arrested for flashing
drivers oh wait what yes yes they were
arrested is it for flashing driver again
like JJ asked did do they have some
footage of that I don't know there's no
footage but they were arrested for Flash
season what do you think guys that's
final round was not an easy one and I
want to thank you oh that's Nina Dobrev
oh God damn
oh I would have crashed my car I would
have like literally my car would have
just flipped like I wouldn't even have
to touch the [ __ ] wheel my car would
have just flipped over
oh exactly why they got arrested oh
she's so goddamn hot
I have very much enjoyed this episode